lining up it's going northbound
[Music]
in Pursuit Houston Orchard
turn your sirens on and sirens on
South and 6-0
in this house in pursuit of the school
and right here
speeds are only like 50 right now across
the land
s here whoa whoa
watch
passing Mitchell
up to the Reddit burner here speeds are
60s
no continuing South hold on slow down
go go
coming up to Beloit speeds aren't that
bad 60 traffic medium pedestrians
it's getting here
coming up to Lincoln going south from
Lincoln through the red so we got the
green go
speeds are only 60. we're pretty close
to it here West South in pursuit of a
red Kia Sportage coming up to Cleveland
Ohio
[Music]
Slow Down slow down
okay uh keep going keep going
cell phone from Cleveland we're gonna
have to is anyone close to us to hit a
car um doesn't look serious here in 603
though we're still behind it speeds are
60 a traffic meeting
slow down
going through the Walgreens parking lot
here go
through the Walgreens parking lot we
were coming up to I think gonna be 6-1
Northbound from Oklahoma
the car's smoking pretty good here
speeds are still only like 50 on
northbound on 6-1 coming back up to
Cleveland
slow down for the stop just past stack
600 stack Northbound speeds are still
only 50 here it's smoking a little bit
no traffic here no pedestrians that I
see
let's hold on slow down for the top Go
Giggle just past Montana coming yeah
back up to Cleveland here we're going
West on Cleveland from six one
let's go
continuing West Side Cleveland probably
at six four now speeds are about 60.
it's about a block and a half ahead of
us traffic is light now no
chasing a stolen red Kia Sportage
[Music]
still continuing Westbound from 6-8 on
Cleveland
speeds are 50 going south on six nine
get up there
[Music]
continuing South on six nine
coming up to Oklahoma gear from six nine
going through a construction zone here
um on the connectnet Easton Connecticut
go go go go
we're going through a construction zone
here
um
702 I'm behind it
I'm gonna call it out for me
please
vehicle
that's going